People used to say comic books were just for
kids, but these days, playing a superhero
on the big screen is an actor’s fastest
way to superstardom.
There aren’t many heroes more beloved than
Batman, set to go from a movie superhero to
a Justice League universe star..
But not every actor to put on Batman’s cowl
ended up a hit – and one of the most influential
men to tackle the role never appeared on film
at all.
Everyone has their favorites so make sure
you let us know yours in the comments below!
Here is Screen Rant’s look at Batman: The
Actors Who Played Him Best.
Adam West
Not every version of Bruce Wayne is shrouded
in darkness, but Adam West's starring role
in the original 1960s Batman TV show wasn't
just campy – it was more profitable and
popular than even modern superhero films could
hope for.
After comics declined during the 1950s, West’s
technicolor take on the hero had entire families
glued to their TV sets.
As parents watched the insane hijinx of West's
caped crusader and the zany villains with
a smirk, the kids took every threat and villain
completely seriously - just like the show's
hero.
In a time when superheroes were anything but
cool, West didn't just have to take part in
absurd storylines, but couldn't be in on the
joke himself – and the fans loved him for
it.
How many modern comedy stars could learn a
lesson from that?
Michael Keaton
Two decades after West hung up the cape, comic
fans thought Tim Burton and Michael Keaton
were giving them another dose of camp with
1989’s Batman.
Instead, they created a version of Batman
who was funny AND terrifying.
Even if he was better known for his comedy
chops, Keaton perfectly captured the tortured,
isolated side of Bruce Wayne, but was playful
enough to make the movie fun, not grim.
Jack Nicholson's Joker gave him a towering
villain to match, and even without Robin by
his side, Keaton was the first actor to win
a Bat-sequel.
Comic fans had sent 50,000 protest letters
to the studio when he was cast, but it was
Keaton who got the last laugh, remembered
as THE definitive Batman for entire generations.
Val Kilmer
Burton and Keaton were impossible acts to
follow, but director Joel Schumacher and star
Val Kilmer tried their best.
With Batman Forever, most of the twisted humor
turned into out of place, cheesy gags, and
most fans gave up hope after one look at the
Batsuit's new nipples.
Kilmer apparently butted heads with the crew
and director on set, but critics agreed that
his playboy persona was as Bruce Wayne was
convincing.
In fact, Batman creator Bob Kane said Kilmer
was the closest he'd seen any actor come to
his own idea of the superhero.
In the end, the movie's villains were more
memorable than the hero, and Kilmer showed
that playing Batman on film relied on a lot
more than brooding and a rubber suit.
George Clooney
After Val Kilmer passed on Batman & Robin,
the studio turned to the one actor who embodied
Bruce Wayne's charm and good looks more than
any man on the planet.
George Clooney's casting made sense – landing
the part right before he became a Hollywood
icon – but trying to recreate the camp of
the '60s TV show, but making sure Batman and
Robin were in on every joke – was a total
failure.
Clooney's dialogue, action and villains might
be "so bad it's good," but the actor has publicly
regretted the film ever since, even apologizing
to fans for ruining the Batman movie series.
He doesn’t deserve all the blame, since
there's no denying that Clooney is as close
as an actor can get to the super-rich ladies
man comic fans have loved for decades.
Christian Bale
By 2005, it wasn't just comic fans who wanted
to see Batman to be taken seriously, but movie
audiences everywhere.
Director Christopher Nolan's Batman Begins
introduced a darker, more realistic version
of Bruce Wayne than any seen before, and Christian
Bale was the only man able to bring the character
to life.
Training in martial arts and packing on muscle
to make sure he looked the part of a superhero,
Bale tapped into the darker, angrier side
of the hero that no other actor had even tried
to touch.
He still had a sense of humor, but it was
the drama and tension that helped the sequel
cross the billion dollar mark at the box office.
Fans can debate the tone, the villains, and
Bale's one of a kind Batvoice, but the actor’s
trilogy of performances mean for millions,
he'll always be The Batman.
Kevin Conroy
Who says you need to be seen to make your
mark on the Dark Knight?
Looking back, it’s hard to believe Warner
Bros. was on board with a cartoon aimed at
an adult audience, even choosing a film noir-influenced
art style for Batman: The Animated Series.
But the writers made sure the stories were
polished, and actor Kevin Conroy provided
a voice for Batman that no fan will ever forget.
It was Conroy who realized that Bruce Wayne
should be the performance, not Batman, and
his voices for each character were an instant
hit.
The actor became the go-to voice of Batman
in animated TV, movies, and the award-winning
Arkham game series.
To this day, the cartoon is hailed as one
of the greatest Batman properties ever created,
and with more than two decades voicing the
hero, it’s safe to say Conroy’s place
in Batman history is guaranteed.
Which of these Batman actors do YOU think
will stand the test of time?
Do the directors and supporting cast deserve
some of the credit, or did one of these actor’s
nail the part better than any other?
Share your own favorites in our comment section
below.
Don't forget to subscribe to our channel and
check out other amazing videos like this one!